Speaker 1: All right, let's try way from Nashville,
Tennessee, way you were on the air.
Speaker 2: Hey, David Pakman.
Yes, I can.
Oh, hey.
So I guess I don't know, I'm kind of seeing
this new Mississippi abortion bill being pushed
to the Supreme Court or the Supreme Court's
willing to examine it.
I haven't looked at it.
Yeah.
So it's it's a new law or Bill from Mississippi
that has something to do with making adjustments
or or limiting Roe v. Wade.
And I just don't see, like, how that could.
I mean, I see, you know, reality since that
the the conservative majority could change
it.
But like what actual common sense is sort
of backing that because we've had Roe v. Wade
in place for, what, 50 years now?
Speaker 1: Yeah, this is the idea here is
not that any one bill is necessarily going
to be what creates alternative precedent to
change Roe v. Wade.
It's they just want to keep hammering, hammering,
hammering.
And as soon as they can get anything favorable
from the Supreme Court, it will then become
the model in more states to clamp down on
abortion.
So I get it.
You look at this one, Bill, and you rightly
say this makes no sense.
We have Roe v. Wade, but that's the whole
point.
Keep sending things up to the Supreme Court
and try to slowly erode abortion rights.
Now, I have to ask you, there's a hissing,
a clapping and horn honking in the background.
Where are you right now?
Describe it to us.
Speaker 2: I'm really sorry.
I'm not at work right now.
I'm walking, like, in the back of the warehouse.
OK, stay away from that stuff.
Speaker 1: Is there a forklift is there a
forklift going by you right now?
Speaker 2: No, but there's these big fans
on the roof that are spinning, and I'm real
sorry about that.
Speaker 1: That's OK.
No, you were well intentioned.
It's a great question.
And the strategy is keep hammering away and
wait until you can get something favorable
from the Supreme Court.
And they just may because we have one of the
most right wing supreme courts in a long time.
Speaker 2: OK, cool.
Also, one more questions like just watching,
like the sort of trash, propaganda and just
bad faith from, like Tucker Carlson and a
lot of other Fox News host and whatnot, like
you think it's worth debating, like like a
Tucker Carlson.
Like, is that going to would that even be
worth time?
Speaker 1: Is it worth it for who to debate?
Tucker Carlson is the question.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I guess I guess that depends,
but it's like, I don't know, like you maybe,
Speaker 1: I mean, sure, maybe.
I mean, you like on his show, you know, here's
the thing about all these questions.
It's like, what's the format?
What's the topic?
What's the point?
Who is the audience?
Where does it air?
There's no one question, the one answer to
these different questions.
I do think it's worth refuting bad ideas and
in that sense, it's worth refuting.
Tucker Carlson.
Speaker 2: All right, well, thanks for taking
my call, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
All right.
We'll let you get back to the warehouse there.
Just a lot going on there, really a lot happening.
But it's great to hear from so many different
people